as soon as this hit and it became super
apparent what was going to be happening
in terms of the economic shakedown I was
like we got to get my me back on the
show you have such an individualized
take like so many people are talking at
a very high level about the economy and
all that but I think it still leaves a
lot of people paralyzed in terms of what
should I be doing right now today so how
do you think about this how does your
normal advice compared to what you're
advising people to do now in the midst
of what's going on I have definitely
made some changes in my financial advice
and one of the first things is that I am
now advising people to target a one-year
emergency fund which sounds like a lot
we can talk about how do you calculate
that and how do you actually do that if
you lost your job for example but that's
one change you know another thing that
I've really been talking to people about
is the psychological mindset of how to
take action right now and you know
there's a little framework that I've
been sharing with people which is step
one is you have to accept reality and
that means that for example if you're a
waiter your jobs not coming back for a
long time and we have to just accept
that that is the case that's really
painful because culturally most of us
are optimistic we want to go west we
think that everything is going to work
out all of our movies and with two
people walking off in the sunset but
sometimes reality is a little tougher
than well the second thing that we have
to do is make a plan it's one thing to
be worried and anxious about money fine
all of us are feeling that way but after
we accept reality
we have to decide hey what if things go
great how am I going to come out of this
but also what if things go poorly and
then finally we have to move in normal
times we are so we get paralyzed and if
you think about if you're driving down
the freeway and you see something in the
middle of the road what's the first
thing you do you slam on the brakes it
makes sense but in a time like this in a
crisis that's actually the last thing
that you want to do you don't want to
what do you mean when you say slam on
the brakes in this you're saying just
don't stop thinking don't stop
processing opening bills moving forward
making a plan
because you see what happens is most of
us freeze we don't know what's gonna
happen we wait for the government to
tell us we wait for our boss to tell us
we wait for everyone around us to tell
us what's going to happen and we
delegate our own authority
now hopefully they know but I think
reality has shown that they don't and so
better that we move instead of staying
stagnant and paralysed and waiting and
listen to this it's even better if you
move and you make a couple of mistakes
as long as you are moving but so many of
us are paralyzed to do anything and that
is the last thing you want to do right
now how the hell do people who are there
living a life where they're just sort of
making ends meet they're living paycheck
to paycheck I think the status most
people if they're hit with a surprise
$500 bill they can't pay it so if
they're in that zone now especially and
I'd love you to answer this two ways how
do they do it if they have their job and
then how do they do it if they just lost
their job okay great let's start with
people who lost their job I want to talk
to them first because it is urgent for
them and other people who still have
their job or have savings you have a
little bit more leeway so for both
groups
the typical advice that you hear is to
shrink and cut back on everything but as
I've always said there's a limit to how
much you can cut there's no limit to how
much you can earn so there are really
three ways that I talk about in terms of
getting stable and it's the CEO strategy
cut costs we all know the flavor but
I'll give you a specific example I had
somebody I'll reach out to me and say
we're meet my wedding isn't for like
seven or eight months what do you think
I should do and I said without missing a
beat I said you got to cancel it and as
someone who has planned a large wedding
I know how painful that is to just think
of all the money lost all the planning
all the time but at a time like this
money in your pocket is worth more than
money in your pocket later
so money in your pocket now is worth
more than money in your pocket later
that means if you have to cancel certain
things that are going to incur fees
later fine deal with the fees later but
get the money in your pocket that's c/e
earn more we can talk about earning more
in a second but there's a whole
opportunity there to start businesses
and start or anymore oh is really
something that a lot of people haven't
thought about right now so whether you
have a job or not you can call up the
companies that you owe money to or you
transact with and you can get some
surprisingly great results for example
your student loan company if you guys oh
no student debt if you owe credit card
debt if you have a cable bill a cell
phone bill or even a landlord you pick
up the phone and this is what you say
you say I've been a good customer for
three years
coded 19 is making it difficult for me
to be able to pay my bills like I
usually do I'd like to know what options
you have available for me and my readers
have used this script a lot of them have
gotten their payments paused with no
finance or interest charges and some of
them have even gotten rent waived so
there's a lot of opportunity you're
talking about possible hundreds or even
a thousand plus dollars with one phone
call that is how you start here's what's
interesting about do-or-die time I don't
wish them on anybody but it is really
fascinating when you're backed into a
corner the reserves emotionally that you
find this is one of the things I find so
interesting about your backgrounds that
you studied psychology so what is it
that makes people so reticent to pick up
that phone and how do you help them over
that hurdle because some people will
hear the logic of hey $1,000 with a
single phone call they're going to do it
other people still want that phone still
heavy do you how do you approach people
that are hesitant I remember hearing a
podcast interview with a former Navy
SEAL and he said when other people do
push-ups they get tired the more
push-ups I do the stronger I get and I
just thought it was such a beautiful
reframe that when things get hard we can
actually get stronger so you know so
many of us wish for things to be easier
and the first question they ask when
they hear that script is can I text them
or email them and that's the wrong
question to be asking because what
you're really saying is that phone
scares me or calling up somebody and
asking for what I want scares me so is
there some
short-cut I can take and I would
challenge everyone here just like you
said I wouldn't wish these times on
anybody but in these times they give us
the opportunity to really rise up and
become bigger than who we previously
were and so if the phone scares your
past self maybe your current self looks
around and says you know what it's time
for me to find a way to overcome that
fear so that is my hope for everyone
here the phone call is actually the
smallest part of how you can transform
yourself right now in retrospect when
you look back on this five years from
now you're gonna look back and say I
can't believe that phone call or I can't
believe starting a business and and
posting something on Instagram selling
something threw 50 bucks scared me
because look how far I've come but you
have to pick up the phone or you have to
post that first sale right now to know
that you can actually be bigger than you
thought you could you know it's so rare
here's someone going on offense with
their money
most often like 99% of the time people
are playing life on defense especially
with their money I guess I spent that
much I don't nobody taught me about
money oh there's no way to make money on
on and on and even in the relatively
simple area of cost-cutting for life
know that I'm going after it I'm gonna
become an animal as you put it and so
you don't have to have that aggression
in every part of your life I think at a
certain point it would become
counterproductive maybe but just to pick
that one zone and say I'm gonna dominate
this and whatever winning means to you
so let me give a couple of suggestions
for people for how you can start and
then how you can take it to the to the
next level if you want to first off with
cutting one common mistake that people
make is they just try to cut a little
bit of everything
5% here 5% their life sucks when you do
that and the classic thing we've all
heard is $3 lattes blah blah blah saving
$3 a lot is not going to change your
life at all
okay I've run the math you save it for
60,000 years maybe you end up with some
real material savings none of us are
doing it you would be better off picking
your two to three biggest expenses and
going after going really hard okay you
got a car payment let's look at that
you know stood
have I called up my student loan company
have I gone and typed in student loan
debt payoff and calculated how I could
shave four years off the payment no
nobody had they spend their life
complaining but they never read a single
good book about personal finance for
their entire life so pick two areas two
to three target 10-15 percent savings if
you can achieve those you don't have to
worry about cutting back on three dollar
lattes those two to three big expenses
can be amazing now if you want to go all
the way like to what you did you can get
aggressive and you can start cutting
everything but I would recommend because
money is also a psychology game is you
want to get a couple of wins under your
belt first so even something as simple
as getting your credit card fee waived
that's 35 bucks it's not that much in
the grand scheme but you're gonna be
like wait a second pat myself on the
back I actually did this and now you can
start to get more aggressive anyone who
has had a long career has had something
bad happened to them I was laid off from
my own company right so there are
everyone who has any experience whether
you're an employee or an entrepreneur
has had something bad happen to them and
I say that because I've had my own I
will teach you to be rich readers who
have come to me and some of them as
recently as four weeks ago they were big
ballers they had great jobs they were
doing very well and suddenly they were
laid off through no fault of their own
and now it is humiliating for them to
have to go to the unemployment website
and my first response to them when they
were DMing me was to say these services
are here for you you should not feel
embarrassed about taking advantage of it
they are here for you so if it's a
matter of pride or it's a matter of
feeling bad put it aside write rewrite
that narrative in your head that I'm a
failure because you're not and go take
advantage of every resource you have
available
unemployment is one you should do that
first thing if you've been laid off you
should also take a look at what you can
control with your expenses so let's talk
about that
on your emergency fund what is that a
lot of people have mistakenly think hey
I make 60 K a year my emergency fund
needs to be 60 K there's no way I can
save 60 K that's crazy well you don't
need 60 K in full for your emergency
fund so let's break it down the way you
do it is you imagine what is the minimum
amount of money you need to live to
cover your rent you know if you or your
partner got laid off you would probably
be cutting back quite a bit okay how
much does that cost then you say alright
I am going to take everything that I can
and put it in an emergency fund in cash
just a simple high-yield savings account
you don't need anything fancy now a lot
of people already have some money in
savings they've just never thought of it
as part of an emergency fund other
people have been following my book
they've been automatically investing so
for them I tell them put your
investments on pause and redirect that
money to your emergency fund now it's
probably going to take people a while to
save 12 months but guess what that's
okay even if you get seven months of the
way there that's better than nothing and
once you have that money you have
security you have safety you have the
ability to breathe and think about a
perspective for your job or your
business that you want to start so that
is what I would recommend take advantage
of all the resources you've got redirect
any money you can towards that emergency
fund and remember it doesn't necessarily
have to be your full salary it's
probably a fraction of that we covered
c-cut expenses we covered oh you're
going to optimize the way that you're
spending you're going to get in there
you're going to get reductions and
things talk to me about earning what can
people do now they've lost their job it
is panic mode my first advice was if you
can get a roommate move in back in with
your parents whatever like all the pride
that might be you up literally let it
all go I lived with in my mid-20s I
lived with my mother-in-law so it's like
yeah it just is what it is and I had
zero embarrassment over that let's let's
walk people through like what that would
look like it's funny you know
for the first thing that happened when
coronavirus hit was people started
emailing and DMing me and saying I I'll
tell you about a
real woman who DME and she said Ramiz
I've been following you for three years
she said I'm a nurse and I was playing
around with the idea of starting a
business but seeing everything that's
going on all this follow your passion
build logos it all seems so ridiculous
it seems so foolish and I said to her I
said you know thanks for being in the
healthcare field I appreciate that but
if somebody needs a logo right now
that's not foolish at all so we have to
remember that even when the economy has
crashed people are still willing to pay
for the things that they want and things
that they need and this has been true
for thousands of years people have paid
to adorn themselves with clothes they've
paid for food they've paid for
entertainment so right now what you see
is really two different groups of people
you see the people whose first reaction
is to say why everything won't work oh
nobody will pay for anything there's no
money around and then you see the
entrepreneurs who say wait a minute
it's going to be harder certain
industries are not going to make any
money right now fine let me accept
reality but wow there's a lot of kids
around sitting at home and their parents
will pay anything so that they're
learning something and leaving them
alone so they can work Wow what are you
doing on Friday night nothing like every
other Friday night I will pay for
something that my husband and I or my
wife and I or my girlfriend boyfriend
and I can do just for 20 bucks just to
let us enjoy life for that two hours on
a Friday night so there are massive
opportunities I will tell you that we
have seen our business continue to grow
during this time and I have lots of
examples of my own readers and students
who have grown their businesses during
this time too if you want more advice
wisdom guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me I hope you
find it valuable
continue to believe and I'll
I've made a conscious effort to make
sure I'm more productive